hello everyone I've got a brand new
Sundance 2019 interview for you I am
sitting here with the filmmakers behind
the movie before you know it and we are
really lucky to be here with them thanks
to Kia Telluride thank you so much to
our wonderful sponsor for making these
interviews happen because really excited
to talk about your movie last night at
the premiere you could just feel the
energy and it was just it was a major
crowd pleaser it's funny it's
heartwarming and I really love the
balance between the two so a huge
congratulations to all of you the first
thing I wanted to ask and I assume I can
give this duty to one of you a brief
synopsis for anybody out there who does
not know what before you know it is
about take it away
okay about two sisters in their
childhood home above the family theater
that they own and operate with their
playwright father
Jackie's thirteen-year-old daughter and
they they find out that their mother
they thought was dead is in fact alive
and starring on a soap opera which
happens to have enough after the death
of their father
and so it's really about it's about the
two of them navigating their
relationship in the face of this
complete paradigm shift within their
family structure and growing up it's
like it's a whole family coming of age
and what was it that inspired this story
we've both been really drawn to the
theme of how our respective family
dynamics inform our identity and
sometimes the difficult process of
having to untether yourself from that
family dynamic in certain regards in
order to maintain that sense of identity
and we both had pretty diametrically
opposite upbringing 'z but found that
the the middle of our Venn diagram for
what we find funny was was the pain that
happened to those families that we loved
very much but yes and the initial idea
of sisters who find out their mother's
alive
TV was from beginning of our friendship
first thing we wrote it was Jen's idea
and then over the years as we evolved as
artists and as people and realize what
we wanted to say the challenge became
marrying that larger-than-life
sort of farcical or soap-like premise
with what we were actually experiencing
in our in our lives and what it would
actually mean to find out that a parent
you thought was dead was alive to
realize that the other parent had been
lying to you and so on and so forth I
will let you guys speak to this
eventually about Mike and Judith I think
it's really important when we find two
people who collaborate and have such a
fruitful collaboration together to be
able to celebrate that so I was curious
from your perspective what was it like
working with these two hundred four
ladies here
I'll start is it's really a very special
experience but you know when you when
you say something like that it's like
sounds so generic this is very very
specific I worked with them at the labs
at Sundance it's coming up two years
this June and they're dynamic
interpersonally as you can see how
connected they are really moved the the
needle in terms of the character that
they were asking me to play the script
that was sent to me originally was
already wonderful so in working with
them what ended up happening was there
was a kind of depth and a connection and
one of the things that Jen talks about
is this curiosity that we all had about
each other and we all started sharing
with each other about our growing up in
our lives together
so there was another dynamic that was
coming into play that was creating
something even deeper and more fruitful
and a kind of emotional depth that
they're talking about so that was
fantastic Sundance was amazing in terms
of their support of us and also when you
have that kind of a dynamic something
else begins to happen and you see it on
the screen and you can feel it on the
screen so it's not a question of what
you think about a film it's a question
of what you feel about a film and this
is that a real feeling level and
something we were in a car riding over
here and
Jen said it's about growing up and
waking up it's true as someone who had
to grow up and wake up in New York City
living with my sister oh it really spoke
to me this movie is the same exact
situation but you just you feel that
kind of chemistry in that relationship
radiates off-screen which I think it
could make it something that anybody can
connect to Mike what was it that drew
you to your character um was a piggyback
of what Judith said about I mean talking
about the Epiphany of having someone
lead a certain life having these adults
who are damaged kids essentially having
to deal with these things and we just
sort of weird thrust into their world
and you start to learn little by little
how damaged they are and why they're
damaged and I think you know I think the
great thing about this project is that
they find humor in it because you have
to find humor and everything otherwise
you can't make it you can't tolerate
this pain and it's anguish and so I
think the way the characters deal with
it it's it's funny but it's also very
endearing and very genuine when I saw
the project and I read I think I felt
like I moved to jumped onto a moving
train you know these guys did all the
development here at Sundance and I was
familiar with the Institute and how they
develop projects so what I found out
that this is one of these projects I was
happy because I knew that the work was
kind of already done and that you know I
was literally stepping into something
that was kind of a ready-made bake cake
I mean really I came in I was like sure
I can you know I would love to be a part
of it well it's you know honestly these
guys when I kept when I came on and I
looked at the way they work she this is
your first feature full-length film but
when you do a shorts and you do other
things you're learning and everybody
knows it's all about moment-to-moment
it's all about pieces if you can do one
thing you do the other so that's when I
got on set I realized you know that she
had picked the right crew she picked the
people that she wanted to work with
everybody was like really interesting
people even behind the camera and so
every day felt like you know she was
certain to what she wanted and there was
not a lot of stress and it felt really
good to be a part of this so I was happy
to join on I asked this often and what
you just said reminded me of this
particular question if you had to name
an unsung hero of this movie because we
all know you but from the crew just
someone out there who might not get a
shout out that really deserves it can I
have - you can have as many as you want
Johnny whose last name I forget it
Johnny my spot
johnny was our onset dresser and he he
spent the entire shoot running and he
did the work of what should have been
ten people's jobs and then she's not
totally unsung because I try to credit
her whenever I can but Lauren Taylor our
location manager
I think location managers don't get
enough credit because that's that's
casting it is it's such a huge part of
building out the movie yeah and I
couldn't be happier with the location
she found us and Kristie lets our line
producer who managed to make it work
with our budget and never she never made
me feel like I was gonna have to
compromise because of money she that
there was not my business I'm sure she
had those conversations with my
producers but I didn't have to worry
about it that is a super important piece
of freedom to be able to have while
you're creating something and speaking
of the location manager obviously I told
you guys I'm from New York and I love
how lived in this movie makes New York
Field but I also got these terrible
flashbacks to when I tried to shoot
shorts in New York and there's a million
rules and permits and police and you
can't put the sticks on the ground so
I'm just curious what was your
experience like working so much on the
streets of New York we had the same
thing to myself before again my
producers Mallory Schwartz and rush
Hetzler did such an incredible job of
protecting all of us from from the
stress of production from the stress of
things outside of our control but there
were also like just happy accidents
having to do with the restrictions we
that opening scene I had planned on
shooting coverage I'm not insane you
know I'm just I'm not a I'm not a like
egomaniac I know that like coverage
helps but we and we have this whole plan
we'd rearranged the schedule to make it
work we had brought on extra crew we'd
like you know we had a condor at the end
of the street lighting the whole street
and people called the police to complain
the light was so bright so we had to
flag the light which screwed up all the
lighting man to relay anyway we wound up
having half an hour to shoot that entire
first scene the opening scene of the
movie I might should I share this and
and and just pretty quickly I was like
it's gonna be a winner we're gonna nail
it it's gonna be it's gonna be okay
we're all we're all just gonna stick the
landing and I know we wanted and I know
we can and everyone kind of held their
breath and made it happen the happy
magic of high-pressure situation and
that was because of New York sucking a
little bit and I Love New York also I
think and I I want to hop on just to say
cuz she's not gonna say this about
herself there was such an efficiency of
communication between Hannah and our
producers in all the department heads
that even when things I actually wasn't
in that team but I was sitting on
monitor like stress eating cheese it's
just like how is this gonna go down and
the cops are there and in it it sounds
simple but honestly maintaining a spirit
of calm and end kindness even in the
face of what felt like might be a bit of
a battle there is a trickle-down effect
there and and that really informed the
rest of the shoot and I think ultimately
in front of performances too I assume
you guys would agree with that the vibe
on set just like it's really strong and
I actually want to take a moment to give
a shout out to your younger co-stars
here because they're both fantastic but
it was very surprised that I walked away
from the movie thinking Olivia might be
my favorite character there was just
there was something about her and how
she treats the situation in people
around her I feel like you don't see the
purity of kindness in a young character
like that too often and that really
touched me we did it she's always been
our favorite too at this point she's
actually like 34 I saw her at the bar
last night before her parents are like
what Anna's and and I have to give her a
little one more little brag she's great
at writing kids it's not an easy thing
to do and we would put our heads
together for those younger characters
especially I definitely was following
Hurley
because I think it's it's a really easy
habit to fall into wanting to write you
paint with one color with somebody
that's that young but or cute or cute
yeah and these are these are real people
I was in a lot of pain when I was 13 and
I think I think you did a great job
making sure that they were human really
amazing young women like I I see so many
movies about like bad friendships and
like young women treating each other
badly and that just wasn't my experience
growing up I felt really supported by
and I thought they were emotionally
generous and and so we wanted Olivia to
capture that that version of being a
preteen definite success there because I
wanted to be best friends with her when
I walked out of the movie Judith for
your character here I was wondering
about tapping into almost the satirical
nature of a soap opera but also making
it still feel grounded like like it's in
line with the rest of the movie - and I
think again you achieved that quite well
so can you tell me a little bit about
finding that balance thank you
it came from our time at the lab there's
just was no question about that and like
I said before the script came in in
pretty much full form it's like sort of
what Mike was saying that there were it
was or it was already there they knew
what the challenges were going to be and
we talked a lot about that about that
very fine line that balance teetering on
that balance of not making it a
caricature because I had done a soap for
five years and we talked a lot about
that and what that what that actually is
so that there's underneath there's this
this frailty this vulnerability this
this painful sort of life and guilt and
about a choice that she made so far back
and is trying to fix that now in some
way and it's not terribly successful and
what does it mean to make a choice to
leave your children for yourself it's a
very you know we in our culture we call
that a very selfish thing to do and she
was
looking for herself so we were looking
for the balance of what makes someone
tick underneath what is their psychology
that's running them so that it that can
come to the fore so that's kind of how
we all worked on it together you know
you kind of tapped into the age of her
greatest trauma and and I think there's
some humor in that when you see an adult
who's stuck at that level we actually
that's right we actually we talk yes we
talked
yeah and that was one of the things that
we actually talked about and just
reminded me of that right and I have to
wrap up sadly cuz I have a million more
questions for you I'm also really
fascinated by the whole Sundance Lab
process and I'm thankful we have
something like that but to close this
out for each of you you're all playing
characters that need to grow and change
and they do accomplish that over the
course of the movie but what is one
piece of your character that if you
could take with you for yourself what
would it be and why I think Jackie's the
most hopeful person I've never met I
think that I'm definitely a bit surly ER
and I think the thing in her that I
tried to remember when I felt like I
wanted to judge her because she's an
intense person is that she is on an
Olympic course to maintain a sense of
hope at all times and I think that
that's something that we could use some
of right now totally agree
for me it would be learning that the
immediate discomfort of being honest is
far less painful than the long-term
effect of stifling your needs how about
for you Mike yeah I think I'm Charles is
probably much more organized and I think
he I mean I would never be called and to
do any one's anything you know books
anything I'm just I've a math makes me
cringe and I just I just don't have the
patience it's tedious to me so III
applaud people who do it and I wish I
had carved my brain but I don't
I me I would say that what Hannah said I
would concur about that it's that
telling the truth early on is much
easier and the than the long-term pain
it's like quick now clean under the sofa
you have a lot to learn and also to
forgive myself for the things that I
have called mistakes in the past that
there's never a problem and there's
never an issue and anything can be fixed
and we can you know if you think you've
done something terrible you can pick up
the phone and call somebody pocket that
one for myself thank you guys so much
for your time today again really
charming fun experience and a great
thing to be able to experience with a
packed house at Sundance thank you guys
so much for watching this interview keep
an eye out for before you know it thanks
again to Kia Telluride we will see you
soon with more coverage from Sundance
2019
you